[Musique]
une conférence de presse est tenue à la
Maison Départementale du port en
présence du département de l'État et de
la justice pour mettre à l'honneur les
ISCG intervenant social en commissariat
et gendarmerie pour venir en aide aux
victimes de violence intrafamiliales
quand la victime de ces violences
ose aller vers la police ou la
gendarmerie et il faut bien évidemment
oser le faire et bien il y a l'accueil
de la personne au niveau judiciaire pour
tout ce qui est des procédures
judiciaires organisées par la police et
la gendarmerie mais c'est procédure
judiciaire doivent être accompagnés
aussi de mesures d'écoute de dialogue et
c'est l'accompagnement social qui prend
tout son sens parce qu'une victime doit
être accompagnée il faut l'accompagner
peut-être en termes de logement en
termes de déplacement de protection de
mise en sécurité d'elle-même mais aussi
de ses enfants et donc les travailleurs
sociaux en police agent d'armory le rôle
c'est de mettre en place cet
accompagnement
suite au dépôt de plainte en police et
gendarmerie
écoutez analyser informer et orienter
les ISCG sont une première étape vers
l'aide sociale un intermédiaire entre la
victime et les forces de l'ordre mon
rôle ça va être vraiment de de d'avoir
un premier recueil de données par
rapport à sa situation
l'écouter avoir une écoute active et
bien sûr lui présenter aussi tout ce qui
peut y avoir en terme de solution d'aide
d'accompagnement qui peut être mis en
place d'associations aussi qui peuvent
être sollicités et l'objectif étant bien
sûr de d'amener avant tout à une prise
de conscience de sa situation
en 2021 1657 femmes et 407 mineurs
victimes de violences intrafamiliales
ont pu bénéficier de l’intervention des
ISG
[Musique]